good evening sir thank you so much for
your lecture and my name is AD I have uh
one question uh in an era where we
trying to combat sexism and fe uh sexism
and racism we have they've developed a
new problem which is credentialism of
meritocracy what do you think that we as
individuals or as a collective Society
should ensure that we should do to
combat that problem and it doesn't
further the Gap that exists
already yeah well there is the I I think
that's very important I mean and
meritocracy has sort of got out of hand
and you know I'm a meritocrat I grew up
poor and you know I got where I got to
by working hard and I believed in it for
many years I mean I really thought oh
it's much better me being in charge than
the Juke of wing wang you know who who's
been ruling this place since the
beginning of time um of course when you
think about it hereditary privilege is
no more ethically defensible than
intelligence privilege right and you
know intelligence privilege really has
um problems of its own but when you talk
about credentialism I know an and I have
thought about this a lot because this
divide and widening divide between
people who have a four-year University
degree and people who do not is entirely
artificial you know it's true that if
you get an airplane you would like the
guy who's flying the airplane or the
woman who's flying the airplane to
actually know how to fly an airplane
that seems like a good thing right and
there's lots of things that you want
people well qualified but what we're
doing is we're using the ba as a
Criterion for social respect and even
for self-respect and that is a disaster
we don't need to do that and we've got
to find and that would be one of the
solutions I think would really help is
other roots to self-respect and to
dignity that do not necessarily go
through the educational system we stop
despising people who don't have degrees
and that's part of what I was saying
earlier about listening to the people
who are being hurt um you know we've
become this very self-satisfied
minority of the best and the brightest